Our latest wildflower is not just in charge.
She's got a whole lot of spark
because she is an electrician.
Tanya Hicks was the first African-American woman
to be accepted in the Mississippi Electrical Union.
And the first woman accepted in her local union.
And Tanya is joining us now.
Hi, Tanya,
(audience applauding)
Hi.
What made you want to be an electrician?
Yes. I was at college and I wanted to work in the Pentagon
and work on some sci-fi stuff and my professor said
the best thing I would be able to do was be a teacher,
that there weren't jobs like that available for women.
So that summer I was discouraged, I went
and worked on a construction site
and I saw that electricians use electricity, all day.
And it was, I knew right then, that's what I wanted to be.
I wanted to be an electrician.
Now you started your own business.
And for 15 years you pretended that a man ran your company.
Why did you do that?
Well, I wanted to be taken seriously
and I wanted to be paid equally,
and usually when people find out you're a woman
they want to pay you lesser.
And you don't get the same opportunity.
So I would go a job sites,
they would think I was the cleaning lady,
and then when they would find out that I was a woman
and I was an owner,
they automatically thought that I owned the company
with my husband, and I wasn't even married.
And so I used that as an opportunity to hide
so I had to build up my resume
and also not make being a woman
or a minority my value proposition.
So I did that.
Well, I am really excited to be your apprentice today.
Will you teach me something that I did not know before?
Empower me. Pun intended.
Oh yes, well, today we're going to change out
a regular switch into a motion switch.
And Drew, you have children just like I do,
and you get tired of screaming at kids
to turn off the lights.
Well, when you install a motion switch,
as long as there's no activity in the room,
they're automatically cut off.
So you ready to go?
All right, teach me the ways, Tanya.
Turn me into someone I've always wanted to be,
which is not the damsel in distress who calls for help,
but can do it myself.
So the first thing we're gonna do is
we're gonna make sure that the power's cut off.
All right, so here we go. Power off.
Got it.
Okay. So, next thing you're gonna do
is take your multipurpose screwdriver,
and, to the flathead side and take the switch off.
Turn to the left. At the same time you're doing that,
I'm going to talk about the switch.
When you take that plate off, the switch is,
you'd have about three wires to it, a hot, a switch leg
and a grounding wire.
So the next thing that you want to do is
use the same screwdriver to take out the top
and the bottom screws.
And then just pull it on out.
All right, there we go.
All right.
Okay, Drew, great job.
Next thing you want to do is disconnect the wire.
Okay, so do I wanna take the caps off?
Yes you do, they're wire nuts.
Those are wire nuts, you wanna take those off.
Okay, and then I'm gonna put this in like this, okay.
And then I'm gonna attach all the wires.
Am I just going like, red wire, blue wire,
like classic movie like, attach the wires that are matching?
Yes, you're gonna take the green wire
and put the green wire on the green,
on the wire with the green screw.
You're gonna take your black wire and connect it
with the wires coming out of the black screw.
Now we've already stripped these wires for you, so.
And they put some pigtails on there,
what we call it, for you.
Pigtails, that's cute.
Okay.
Great job, you're doing great.
You have to put those wires on
and push it.
Push all the wires in the box.
Uh-huh.
And you see the screw at the top
and a screw at the bottom?
You're gonna put those screws on.
Yeah. Great job, yeah.
Um.
Yeah the entire job takes 10 to 15 minutes.
So this is awesome. You're doing great.
Yeah, yeah, so now you have that on,
and you can put the plate on.
Yes, that's it.
And then you want to turn the power on.
You did a great job.
All right, I'm gonna flick the power on.
Yes.
And then here we go, ready?
Boom!
(audience applauding)
Tanya, if I walk by a light switch now,
I feel like I actually know what it looks like inside.
I know what to do, I know what wires to match
and I feel like I've seen something
that was completely mysterious to me before
and I thank you for illuminating, I did it again,
me into not feeling so helpless,
and opening up a whole new world to me.
Thank you.
You're welcome, Drew.
Well, thank you, Tanya.
And we're honored to get the word out about you.
You are such an inspiration for all the roads you are paving
for everyone else.
Thank you so much.
You're welcome, thank you for having me.
Thank you, Tanya.
(upbeat music plays)